right solid solid wins this game going
away going away so just take your time
out there be sure of everything hit
singles
[Applause]
so Jason Kidd is at Mid Court having a
conversation with
the officials
[Applause]
as to whose Possession It is an official
said it was Dallas fall before timeout
they were giving them all to Golden
State
[Music]
cavan Looney made a basket but
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so there was an offensive
rebound the ball one out of bounds off
of Looney it's Dallas ball but I think
Jason Kidd was still wondering why
wasn't Dallas ball to begin with back to
about the two minute Mark watch here
Dallas thinks it's their ball out of the
timeout the Warriors are inbounding
under the Dallas basket you saw halloumi
start to run the other way and then he
realizes wait we have a layup but the
Mavs were under the assumption it was
their ball and I think that's how it was
originally count called and then there
was a stoppage to try to explain it but
I get now why
we were actually looking at the monitor
because Steve Kerr was on that wire clip
as to Michael green with a blow by and
dunk I mean
that's the oddest thing I've seen in
some time usually the officials would
call everybody down
if there's any confusion as hard he gets
a nice curl layup I I was surprised they
didn't manage that situation well with
the confusion of whose ball it was and
also tell Dallas no the ball
is here because Dallas was certainly
under the impression it was their ball
coming out of the timeout I even think
the warriors were
[Applause]
as a defensive three seconds but but if
you're managing that situation you
emphatically bring Dallas down as an
official you don't inbound the ball it
looked like the officials thought the
ball was going the other way as well
everybody was confused
it cost Dallas a bucket
and you know those things
can cost you a season